not getting enough sleep won't just make
you cranky
it could kill you the united nations
even considers sleep deprivation a form
of
torture and the longer it lasts the
worse
it'll get losing sleep affects people
differently
but generally the effects increase as
the hours do
just 48 hours without sleep is
considered extreme sleep deprivation
but you'll probably get weird before
then after 18 hours with no sleep
you might feel a little drunk staying
awake that long is equivalent to having
a blood alcohol content of 0.05
which is what you get with three or four
drinks in the span of two hours
24 sleepless hours that bac comparison
jumps to
0.1 percent higher than the legal
driving limit in every state
you might feel foggy less alert or
uncoordinated
almost like you're wearing sleepy beer
goggles including double or blurry
vision
that's because sleep deprivation slows
down our brain cells ability to talk to
each other
so if you actually are drinking alcohol
drowsiness can increase its effects
and while caffeine could make you feel
more alert for several hours
it'll only work up to a certain point by
a day and a half this could all get
worse and then some
your chances of getting sick are higher
than usual because your body can't fight
like it normally can
and around this time your brain and body
get so
tired that you start experiencing micro
sleeps
tiny periods of sleep may be around 30
seconds that you might not even notice
definitely annoying and even dangerous
if you're doing something like
driving a car and then there's the
potential for hallucinations
visual distortions are most common your
water bottle grows to twice its size
or moves around the room but you could
also experience sensational or auditory
hallucinations
things like feeling someone who's not
there tap you on the shoulder
or hearing your name being called once
you hit
48 hours it's literal torture which is
why extreme sleep deprivation studies
are now prohibited by
law in most countries two days without
sleep can cause you to start losing your
grip on reality hallucinations worsen
and you might even undergo
depersonalization
that's the feeling that reality is
slipping away which may or may not
include an
out-of-body experience tack on extreme
anxiety irritability stress
and fatigue and it's no wonder the un
doesn't allow this kind of deprivation
after 72 hours you're not gonna be able
to think about
anything but hitting the hay forget
about doing simple tasks
things like getting dressed or finding a
snack could feel
overwhelming partially from fatigue and
partially because your ability to
regulate emotions
is basically out the window your
hallucinations could get more complex
creating fully formed images like a
person or
a bear or maybe a car you shouldn't
drive
and in at least four historical sleep
studies participants reported
shared hallucinations namely something
called the hat phenomenon
which is basically a feeling of pressure
around your head as if you're wearing a
hat
all of this opens the door for paranoia
depression and delusions
which brings us to 96 hours or more with
no sleep
say bye bye to reality folks more and
worse hallucinations and paranoia could
lead to sleep deprivation psychosis
a total snap from the real world
historically
women accused of being witches were kept
awake long enough to trigger this
psychosis
judges considered their visions and
ramblings confessions
leading to the women's convictions now
the fifth day
is sometimes called the turning point
this is the danger zone
your mental health takes a sharp decline
cementing your delusions as your new
reality
eventually your brain will stop
functioning properly in a way that could
lead to organ failure
and in rare cases death luckily
recovering from sleep deprivation can be
as simple as catching up on sleep
but if you're sleep-deprived regularly
you're looking at long-term effects like
weight gain
acne headaches and high blood pressure
among other things
and it can take weeks to get back on
track according to one study
you need four days to recover from
losing a single
hour of sleep try getting to bed early
instead of sleeping in late
or better yet avoid the recovery period
entirely
by getting seven to eight hours of sleep
every night
in the first place